ALWAYS BEING ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Austin: THATE
TONIGHT ON THE NBA.
>> Austin: I LIKE
COLLINS.
YOUNG ON THE RUN.
STRONG SIDE OR THE WEAK SIDE.
>> Brad: CATCHES T
BAD ONE THAT
MADE THE
6-4 THE EARLY CAVALIERS LEAD.
HUNTER DOWN THE SEASON.
OKORO FINDS OKOROID HAWKS REBOU.
HE
PICKED OFF B TRIGGERS.
AND OUR DEFENSE HAS TO
IMPORTANT THE 3 BALL IT BUT I
WOUL DEFENSE BY THE
CAVs.
REBOUN
YOUNG
EXECUTE AND SHARE THE
BASKETBALL.T SECOND DOES.
>> Austin: TAKING HIS TIME ANDT.
KEVIN LOVE BACK IN THE BALLGAME.
YOUNG INSIDE EITHER A NOW
>> John: HUNTER TO THE FOUL
LINE.IT.
TO COLLINS THINGS.
DOUBLE AND TRAP.
HIM.
THEY HAVE TO COME THE WILD SHOT.
>> B
REPLACED COLLINS.SHOT.
OUT COME THE CAVALIERS.
GAME.
A DOZEN POINT AND 10 REBOUNDS
AND 4 CLOCKS.
THE
THEY CAN DO IT. THE POSSESSION.
>> John: RUBIO. HUERTER.
A LONG  OSMAN TO THE FOUL LINE.
LOBS TO.
GIVE THEM CREDIT.
>> John: SEXTON BLO WE DON'T
KICK POINTS
IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
>> B DID WITH EVAN SHOT.
COLLIN SEXTON GETS FIRED UP.
>> [WHISTLE]. WORK BY LOVE.
MARKKANEN SWATS IT OUT AG IN TH
4TH QUARTER.
>> Brad: SCENE.
>> Brad: GETTING MAN.
>> John: YOUNG MISSED THE SHOT.
MARKKANEN TIPS THAT. VISITORS.
>> Brad: THAT SAYS THAT.
>> Austin: EVEN 2 BOTH.
>> Brad: CAVs ONLY
CAPELA TOUCHES.
THE CAVs BENCH IS GOI
>> John: RUBIO.
HUNTER.
HAWKS